and then when i sat and watched blade  runner 2049  um as much as i appreciate denis and i  think that he is one of our best  directors i think that he in that film  almost every scene in 2049  runs too long  it goes past its  natural expiration date right so you  have this natural point where the it  feels like the the scenes that's it  let's go to the next scene and we are  still there for a minute or two  afterwards i think that's the flaw of  2049 is there's a there's a lot to like  in that film but  usually my role ruled is this whenever i  look at a film it's almost always this  right less is more  almost always  and i think 2049 at less is better than  2049 at moore which is what we got